she was like i don't want to share
you as a boyfriend with courtney
and then she literally said with an
ultimatum
you have to choose me or courtney
scott disick says sofia richie gave him
an
ultimatum between her and kourtney
kardashian
as khloe kardashian reveals she almost
lost her daughter true while she was
pregnant
i almost miscarried with true at the
beginning it
all went down on thursday's 20th and
final season premiere of keeping up with
the kardashians
tune in because you never know what's
going to happen during a chat with kim
and chloe
scott opens up about his relationship
with sophia
which he says came to an end when the 22
year old gave him an
ultimatum between her and his family
life with courtney
i was like but courtney is courtney and
my kids it's a
unit it's a package deal and i said i
was like how could you even
want that for me it just became like
an impossible relationship to keep
carrying on with sometimes it's time
just to cut the cord
yeah like i need to be with somebody
that i trust both courtney and scott who
continue to co-parent the three children
they have together
have moved on to new relationships since
they filmed that episode
scott made things instagram official
with 19 year old
amelia hamlin in february while courtney
and travis barker went public with their
relationship
in january i'm never gonna give up my
relationship with courtney and the
co-parenting we have
nothing in a million years will be worth
what we have and i truthfully believe if
the right person were to even come along
into courtney's life
or my life us having children and having
this amazing relationship
would only be a plus to the outsider in
fact they're so good at the co-parenting
thing
court's sister chloe gave them mad props
during a chat with e.t
in 2019. i'm so proud of them and i'm so
proud of them promoting that
it's a beautiful thing to get along with
each other and for your kids to see that
and speaking of coco and co-parenting
also during the episode
chloe who has been candid about pursuing
her plans for a second child with
tristan thompson
has a convo with kim about surrogacy
like i did a check and blood panels and
all this stuff and she just said that i
would be
like a high-risk carrier for a pregnancy
i'm not going to get into specifics on
camera but they said
like it's an 80-something percent chance
that i will miss carrie
i almost miscarried with drew at the
beginning
but i didn't know that was like a
lingering thing kim who shares four
children with her ex
kanye west had some serious
complications during her first two
pregnancies and had her two youngest
psalm in chicago via a surrogate
i mean i honestly had the best
experience with surrogacy
you'll see that the love that you have
for your kids is exactly the same like
there's no difference you know except
for there was someone else that was the
carrier
this all echoes what kim told et back in
2017
when she was expecting her daughter
chicago i think it's
a definitely a different experience and
i'm blessed that i'm
able to do this and that technology is
the way that it is that we can do this
as for chloe she admits she finds her
situation
quote scary and shocking i'm really
grateful that there are other options
but
i love being pregnant with drew my
little
my babe it's such a beautiful experience
to have
big belly i love you baby knowing i
might never get to feel like that again
it's daunting it's scary it's
stressful and it breaks my heart
and while chloe might not be able to
carry baby number two
herself she and tristan did move forward
with ivf
and she reveals they were able to make
three embryos
two boys and one girl it's such a
blessing we have all this modern science
and technology and everything we have
available to us but it's still been a
really strange
way to go about it when you have to do
it like this it gets sometimes it just
takes the fun out of it or yeah it takes
the takes a little bit of the wild
craziness out of it but you know as long
as you got your backside you'd be just
[Music]
fine you